[Música]
el expresidente peruano Alejandro Toledo
está a disposición de las autoridades de
Perú tras ser extraditado desde Estados
Unidos el ex mandatario ya pasó por la
sala penal nacional la justicia peruana
lo acusa de recibir sobornos millonarios
a cambio de licitar obra pública a la
empresa odebrecht
[Música]
miles de personas se dirigen a Ciudad de
México desde la frontera con Guatemala
formando una caravana los migrantes
exigen la aceleración de su solicitud de
asilo en Estados Unidos y el cierre de
los centros de detención
avanzan los combates en Sudán entre el
ejército y los paramilitares a pesar de
La tregua acordada hay escasez de
suministros en los hospitales y caída de
internet en casi todo el país Estados
Unidos Francia y Reino Unido informaron
que evacuaron a sus nacionales
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos esta edición informativa en Perú
porque allí terminó la audiencia de
verificación de identidad del
expresidente Alejandro Toledo en la sala
penal nacional en Lima después de ser
extraditado desde Estados Unidos Toledo
está ahora bajo custodia de las
autoridades peruanas que lo van a
procesar por corrupción concretamente la
justicia lo acusa de recibir sobornos
millonarios durante su mandato
presidencial a cambio de citar obra
pública a la empresa odebrecht Toledo
entra en prisión preventiva en el mismo
centro carcelario donde se encuentran
tanto Alberto fujimori condenado por
crímenes contra los Derechos Humanos
como Pedro Castillo en prisión
provisional acusado de Rebelión
Pero lo único que pido
es que no le corro a la justicia Pero le
pido por favor no me maten en la cárcel
déjeme de luchar
con nuestros argumentos
Ese fue el pedido que Alejandro Toledo
quien lideró Perú durante el período de
2001 a 2006 Y que ahora tras ser
extraditado de Estados Unidos afrontará
un juicio por corrupción en el caso
odebrecht que la justicia de Perú lleva
desde 2017
Toledo es señalado de recibir 35
millones de dólares en conceptos de
soborno por parte de la constructora
brasileña para beneficiarse de la
licitación para la construcción de la
ruta interoceánica Sur que une a Perú
con Brasil
declarar fundado el requerimiento de
prisión preventiva planteada por el
Ministerio Público y en consecuencia se
dicta prisión preventiva al investigado
Alejandro Toledo manrique
por el plazo de 18 meses la fiscalía
peruana ha pedido apenas de 20 años y
seis meses de cárcel por la concesión de
los tramos 2 y 3 35 años por el tramo 4
y 16 años y ocho meses por el presunto
lavado de dinero en el caso de coteba
Toledo es una figura resonante más de la
política latinoamericana que está
envuelta en la Macro trama de corrupción
de odebrecht específicamente en Perú
este asunto también involucró el sucesor
de Toledo Alan García quien fue
investigado hasta que se quitó la vida
en 2019 además la trama alcanzó a los
expresidentes ollanta humala actualmente
en prisión y a Pedro Pablo kuczynski que
pasó varios años en prisión domiciliaria
y se encuentra a la espera del juicio
y continuamos en Perú Porque mientras
este domingo la atención está puesta en
la situación procesal del expresidente
Alejandro Toledo la actual presidenta
Dina boluarte cambió su gabinete de
gobierno un movimiento criticado por la
oposición en las horas más bajas de
popularidad de la mandataria la
presidenta renovó los ministerios de
Justicia educación trabajo y Comercio
en otras noticias avanzan los combates
en Sudán a pesar de La tregua acordada
el viernes continúan los enfrentamientos
entre el ejército regular y el grupo
paramilitar fuerzas de apoyo rápido este
domingo varios países confirmaron la
evacuación de sus nacionales como
Estados Unidos Francia Turquía o Reino
Unido
y en medio de los enfrentamientos en
Sudán son los grupos de activistas
prodemocracia conocidos Como comités de
resistencia los que organizan la
asistencia básica para la población por
ejemplo facilitan la evacuación de
civiles y la atención médica en un
contexto en que los hospitales se quedan
sin recursos el informe es de Samuel
Salgado
en medio de una guerra por el poder en
Sudán los civiles se organizan para
coordinar la asistencia médica y la
evacuación en medio de los intensos
combates en la capital jartum el
ejército y el grupo paramilitar fuerzas
de apoyo rápido se disputan el control
Cuando comenzó la crisis y la guerra en
Sudán la gente se sorprendió y no sabían
qué hacer entonces comenzaron a
compartir lo que necesitaban en redes
sociales y quienes tenían suministros
disponibles los compartían tenía un
sitio web personal y lo convertí en una
plataforma dedicada a publicar pedidos
de ayuda y anuncios de suministros
Adele es desarrollador web y hace parte
de un comité de resistencia como son
conocidos en Sudán estas redes de ayuda
humanitaria los comités han encabezado
un movimiento social y político a favor
de la democracia en Sudán desde 2019 y
han enfrentado la represión del actual
régimen militar instaurado tras el golpe
de estado en 2021
los métodos informales que servían para
organizar manifestaciones contra el
gobierno de facto Ahora son utilizados
para coordinar ayuda humanitaria en las
redes sociales hashtags como not to
world se han viralizado y habitantes de
barrios asolados por la violencia en
jartum integraron grupos de WhatsApp
la gente comienza a unirse llegamos a
1200 personas y todo se comunican bien
en cada uno de los grupos de área cada
vez que revisó un área determinada me
doy cuenta que las personas realmente se
están comunicando y logramos obtener
medicamentos alimentos para algunos todo
va bien el propósito de Esto va bien
quienes quieren huir de la violencia
dependen de los comités para obtener
combustible pero su trabajo depende de
un hilo debido a la falta de apoyo
económico de organizaciones
internacionales y a la afectación en el
servicio de internet
actualizamos ahora la información
relativa a la guerra en Ucrania Por qué
este domingo el instituto por el estudio
de la guerra de Estados Unidos confirmó
que las tropas ucranianas cruzaron a la
orilla Oriental del río nieper cerca de
la ciudad de gersón las tropas de kiev
se acercan así a las posiciones rusas en
la zona nuestra enviada especial a
Ucrania Catalina Gómez Ángel nos amplía
la confirmación fue hecha hoy por el
instituto de estudios de la guerra un
centro de pensamiento con sede en
Washington que sigue día a día lo que
sucede en Ucrania y sigue también con
gran interés lo que dicen los llamados
mini bloggers rusos que son periodistas
o activistas en el terreno activistas
rusos que van contando en la aplicación
de Telegram todo lo que va sucediendo en
el terreno ya llevaban días diciendo que
había presencia de tropas ucranianas en
el lado este del río sin embargo hasta
ayer hubo confirmación de que realmente
estaban hubo vídeos que lo confirmaban
Así que lo que cuenta este instituto es
que si bien se sabe de la presencia de
estas tropas también se sabe que han
hecho misiones de reconocimiento no se
sabe ni qué número ni tampoco el tipo de
armamento que tienen ni qué tan
extendidas están sus posiciones sin
embargo Esta es una gran noticia para
para Ucrania por dos motivos primero
porque puede impedir esos ataques
sistemáticos o por lo menos hacerlos
menores hacer que sea más difícil los
ataques contra la ciudad de gersón la
única capital de provincia que estuvo
bajo control Ruso y que estas tropas se
retiraron de allí en noviembre pasado
después de una gran presión de las
tropas ucranianas y Se tomaron sus
posiciones al lado este del río la
presencia de los ucranianos en este
lugar donde estaban los rusos hace
pensar que ellos retrocedieron hacia
posiciones urbanas más adentro de la
región de gersón todavía en control de
Moscú hará la vida tal vez de la
población de gersón mucho más tranquila
pero también abre el interrogante sobre
si estos son los primeros pasos para la
llamada contraofensiva en las que las
fuerzas ucranianas buscan retomar el
control
regiones del Sur en poder de Moscú esta
contraofensiva Se esperan las próximas
semanas y meses el gobierno de Ucrania
Cómo es su tradición continúa con el
silencio y no ha confirmado nada de lo
que ha sucedido en esta región de jerson
y en noticias de América Latina cerca de
3.000 personas salieron desde la ciudad
mexicana de Tapachula en la frontera con
Guatemala hacia Ciudad de México
formando una nueva y masiva caravana los
migrantes se piden que se acelere su
solicitud de asilo en Estados Unidos y
que México cierre los centros de
detención recordemos que el mes pasado
40 personas murieron en un incendio en
un centro de migrantes en Ciudad Juárez
ante lo que varias ongs denunciaron como
inacción de Los vigilantes
estamos protestando por las cuarenta
muertes de Ciudad Juárez para que
cierren los institutos de migración para
que el presidente Obrador mire que
realmente es una una buena causa que
destituyan al director de migración
porque son estos son los campos de
concentración en los búnkeres de este
siglo el reclamo que desaparezca el
Instituto Nacional de Migración queremos
justicia para la comunidad migrante que
que fallecieron y pues que los que los
este que los vetan a la cárcel a todas
las culpables y el 23 de abril se
conmemora el día del idioma inglés y del
idioma español marcados en el calendario
en recuerdo de la muerte de William
Shakespeare y Miguel de Cervantes
respectivamente aprovechamos la fecha
para analizar el debate sobre la
evolución del lenguaje como consecuencia
de la evolución de las sociedades para
ello conectamos desde Buenos Aires con
la doctora en lingüística Carolina tossi
Carolina Buenas tardes para usted le
quiero empezar planteando que a medida
que abren debates por ejemplo sobre la
identidad de género estos a debates se
trasladan al uso del lenguaje y a la
representación le pregunto Cuáles son
los principales argumentos a favor y en
contra de ampliar el vocabulario para
dar cabida a todas las representaciones
Hola buenas tardes Muchas gracias por la
invitación
Bueno la verdad que es muy muy
interesante
el chiste porque Bueno desencadena una
serie de debates y de controversias el
lenguaje inclusivo en realidad o
lenguaje
incluyente no también como se conoce
este en gran parte de latinoamérica y
también de España no podemos decir que
es un cambio lingüístico todavía porque
para que haya un cambio lingüístico
tiene que ser utilizado por toda la masa
de hablantes Entonces tenemos que
esperar unas décadas para ver si bueno
justamente podemos hablar de un cambio y
de un cambio en la lengua no porque
tenemos que pensar que el lenguaje
inclusivo supone una serie de cambios
morfológicos que se aplican a todo el
sintagma no por ejemplo a partir del uso
de la e por eso podemos hablar ahora de
que se trata de una intervención
discursiva es decir diferentes este
grupos de hablantes utilizan estos
recursos que en la oralidad se destaca
Bueno por el uso de la e pero también en
la escritura se re bueno hace unos años
el arroba no era muy utilizado también
el asterisco pero era principalmente se
utiliza la x bueno los argumentos a
favor tienen que ver bueno justamente
con o sea hacer visible no en la lengua
estos este cambios que tienen que ver
con Mostrar las diversidades sexo
genéricas es decir aquellas este
aquella población que justamente no se
corresponde o no se identifica con la
diferencia femenino masculino con el
binarismo Y entonces por eso abogan por
estos usos
bueno en este sentido sabemos que
muchísimas este posiciones en contra y
tienen que ver más que nada con una
visión más que nada purista de la lengua
es decir bueno no tiene que cambiar la
lengua y también por esta cuestión bueno
que son grupos minoritarios que quieren
cambiar el idioma en este sentido bueno
Tenemos que tener en cuenta que la
lengua no cambia por voluntad de un
determinado grupo sino que bueno
justamente
como yo les decía hace un ratito con las
décadas vamos a ver si este cambio este
tiene asidero o no Claro Carolina Porque
detrás de todos estos argumentos una
pregunta que me surge Y supongo que a
gran parte de nuestra audiencia es hasta
en qué medida el lenguaje moldea nuestro
mundo o más bien solamente lo nombra no
exactamente lo que pasa es que a ver
tenemos que ver que la lengua es cambio
no no O sea no no hay nada estático
pensemos que no hablamos igual no sé si
pensamos Cien años ni hace diez años
Entonces estos cambios van a ir
surgiendo Es cierto que hay que ver si
se asimilan en la lengua o no Si si por
ahí quedan en esta manifestación
disruptiva o de protesta y de intento
bueno por una cuestión política de
mostrar las disidencias sexo genéricas o
no o si después se introduce por ejemplo
este algún pronombre neutro o este o si
la es no como un cambio morfológico se
va este asentando es cierto que no
podemos este darle la espalda a los
cambios no que hay en la en la sociedad
y justamente vos que hablabas de este
tema no de que hoy se celebra el Día de
la lengua española yo creo que en El
Siglo 21 podemos pensar esto que la
lengua española son variedades
discursivas no son todas esas variedades
que se producen en los diferentes este
lugares ciudades pueblos de España y
latinoamérica por eso no podemos hablar
de una lengua pura neutraséptica sino
que la lengua es eso es variedad
Carolina Lamentablemente se nos acaba el
tiempo para continuar abordando
abordando este debate tan amplio pero
muchísimas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros en
cuatro Muchísimas gracias por el espacio
y a ustedes Muchísimas gracias por su
atención enseguida volvemos
[Música]